make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and
most of you guys know
i don't really believe in and straight
out trashing comics which is just like
uploading a video and then just talking
about how crappy a comic book is
i think i may have done that a couple
times but for the most part i usually
just kind of write a comic off and just
sort of be like yeah you know it's not
really my thing and then just kind of
call it a day
but i think we can all almost
universally agree that brian michael
bendis's handling of superman in action
comics was just
bad that the only story i liked was the
house of l and that was the first story
more or less because i was curious
and then it felt like it just went
downhill from there so i didn't buy it
we didn't cover it and
until brian michael bendis was off of
superman i had no intention of having
anything to do with it here's the cool
thing
it looks like dc is largely playing
cleanup duty to make up for brian
michael bendis's superman and so what we
get here
is superman red and blue which is an
anthology book and so this contains
a series of different stories that are
written by different writers and drawn
by different artists now this first
story is the one that we're going to
cover here in this video and this one
doesn't really have a title but it's
written by john ridley and
if this is any indication of the
direction that dc is going to go in with
superman from here on out i am
hyped because this story is amazing
right so what this does is initially
opens up with superman talking about the
idea that like his palms are sweating
and that the only time he's really
perspired
was at one point in the past when he
basically had to save
five billion lives by moving a planet
right and that it took every ounce of
strength in order for him to be able to
pull that off
the only other time he perspired like
this is when he's returning to a place
called lubania
here in the current moment now a little
bit of explanation here lubania as it
was depicted in dc comics was an actual
nation state that existed in central
poland
uh and was introduced back in world's
finest 192 and 193 in the 1970s
and the idea behind this was that
lubania was part of the eastern bloc at
one point in time now for those of you
guys who are not familiar with that as
most of you guys know we had world war
ii and then following world war ii you
had what was in effect
the worldwide battle between like
communism and capitalism right so the
united states and allied countries which
promoted the idea of capitalist
economics and then you had the ussr
which was initially led by stalin
followed by nikita khrushchev which
promoted communism now it's not really
true communism it's leonidas communism
or vanguard communism so like communism
with a central government which is
not really marxist is not only the way
that it was supposed to be but what you
also had was the eastern bloc
and the eastern bloc were basically a
series of european countries that had
been taken over by russia
and enveloped into the ussr so this was
part of poland
this included several other nations and
so the way that it's presented here is
that because the ussr ruled with an iron
fist
alongside any of the satellite states
that were a part of it lubania being one
of those satellite
states was ruled much the same way that
the ussr was right
the almost complete curtail of civil
liberties no real progress right just
straight up oppression in the sense that
communism was the only way to live
and those individuals who lived under
this this twisted version of communism
ultimately ended up being oppressed by
the people who were ruling them so their
technology was decades behind they just
hadn't really caught up with the modern
era
and so superman had visited this place
at some point in the past
really violating international treaties
in order to stop like a train crash
and so the cool thing about this is that
the way this is done it lives up to the
red and blue
situation it's not designed to be
superman red and blue from like the
1990s where he was like the man of
energy and all that garbage instead
superman red is kind of superman as we
know him and then superman blue is
basically clark kent it's designed to
kind of highlight these two
almost diametrically opposing views of
how clark ken and superman function
and so it's one of these things where he
kind of talks about like you know he's
he was he was superman right like he was
the man of steel
nothing could stop superman right
nothing could get in the way of superman
who cares about international treaties
he was doing the right thing right he
was doing what needed to be done
and so what he ends up doing where he
kind of reflects on this is he asked the
cab driver while he's on his way to this
interview
to make a stop he pulls up in front of
the kalemnik reeducation facility which
is
something that you saw pretty frequently
under stalin and nikita khrushchev's
regime
which was basically those individuals
who believed that communism was not the
way
who believed that like the ussr and its
satellite states were wrong would
literally be rounded up and taken to
these concentration camps or
re-education camps so they could be
quote unquote
educated in the right way of thinking
right so they could be taught how they
need to think in order to
fall in line with society and so the
result of this is that superman
initially tried to escape
but the problem he ran into was that the
government of uh labini at the time had
basically found a way to emit low-grade
kryptonian radiation which was not
enough to kill him but it was enough to
bring his powers down and so ultimately
he was captured and then thrown into an
internment camp where he remained
for eight months now the way this is
described by ridley is
not we're not really given anything
graphic in terms of depiction but the
insinuation
is exceedingly graphic in the sense that
superman was one
used as a propaganda piece right that
the eastern bloc the ussr
and lavinia had basically kind of come
out and said look we captured superman
right we captured the man of steel look
how weak the west is right the west
comes here with their capitalist
mentalities and so on and so forth you
know they send their man of steel here
to you know defeat us and to take us
over
and look how we've captured him right
and that was the way the cold war
unfolded
that you saw a lot of that happening one
of the reasons why we call it the cold
war is because you never actually saw
the united states and the soviet union
go to war against one another instead it
was a series of proxy wars right so the
korean war the united states sending
soldiers into china the soviet
afghan war the vietnam war the cuban
missile crisis
this is the kind of situation that we're
talking about it was basically just a
series of smaller conflicts where it was
capitalism versus communism
in this country and in that country and
in that country and that was basically
it but a lot of it was also
propaganda and so any opportunity the
eastern bloc
had to show the west as being weak is
one that they took
and so what readily insinuates here is
that there was
some bodily violations that happened at
the at the direction of koslop
the guy who was basically running this
entire camp who essentially instructed
other soldiers to do these
exceedingly heinous things to superman i
will let your imagination kind of run
wild on what happened again we're not
explicitly told anything but that's
really the insinuation that we get and
here's the important thing behind this
right
for any man out there worth his salt
this is the most grave offense that a
person can possibly inflict on a man
right that while there is this mentality
that like men need to you know emit
emotions and all that kind of stuff
that's a that's a ridiculous philosophy
and any man who believes it is
ridiculous for believing it but the
but there is a measure of pride among
men and the sense that
if you're subjected to you know what
amounts to torture
in such a way that it crushes you but it
takes away everything that makes you
feel like a man and it was a
it's a way for ridley to kind of depict
superman in a way that we've never seen
him before we've seen superman come
close to death
we've seen superman lose its powers
we've seen him mutated we've never seen
superman humiliated and violated in such
a way
in an internment camp in the eastern
bloc by some pretty
screwed up guys we've never really seen
that before and while it's not something
that it's just kind of like yeah man
they tortured superman it is certainly a
thing where it changes the way you see
him
because superman's stories are best told
when there's a way to kind of bring him
down to humanity's level
and make it look like he's really not
that different from us that's where the
best stories come in if you go and you
read peter tomasi's
superman or you go when you read dan
jurgen's action comics you get that
right you get these stories where like
superman's talking to his son
jonathan and teaching him what it means
to be a hero and feels
so human when he does it that's where
the best superman stories come from and
so after experiencing that he actually
ends up going back you know getting back
in the cab
and then heading to the interview only
for us to find out that koslov is the
person that he's actually interviewing
and the way this worked is that with the
fall of the eastern bloc
and the fall of the soviet union that
most of these countries out there were
just kind of left to their own devices
to succeed uh to a degree there was a
lot of capitalism that was thrown into
these places so to give you guys a
little bit of perspective here when the
soviet union fell
right and and essentially the world had
kind of come to this understanding that
vanguard communism as it was practiced
by the ussr and as it's practiced by
china and a few other places
seemingly doesn't work now china's
managed to kind of find a way
to blend their communist economics with
like capitalist economics and create a
kind of hybrid there but the important
thing here is that uh that it was
established that like the the capitalist
nations quote unquote
had one and so what this led to was a
lot of these countries that were
formerly part of the ussr
experiencing liberation but because they
had essentially lived under the yoke of
oppression
both through the germans during world
war ii and then the russians post world
war ii
there was no real knowledge on how to
like rule right there was no real
knowledge on like how they should
function and so what you saw was a lot
of capitalist
economics being injected as well as a
lot of lessons being
learned where the soviet union had
basically failed and so this led to
to this particular country lubania
essentially experiencing this economic
explosion right where they started
bringing in capitalism
and then using it as a means to like
produce goods and basing their entire
economic model off of the capitalist
model they started blowing up in terms
of wealth now we're not given the
details of this and honestly we don't
need it what we are told is that koslov
had actually created a company that's
grown with the wealth of lubania but the
other thing that sort of went on here
and the reason why he is effectively
freed because at one point
he had essentially fallen out of favor
with the ruling government
of lubania and then was actually thrown
inside of his own concentration camp and
when the eastern bloc
fell and lubania was basically freed and
liberated he was just kind of thrown out
there but in the immediate aftermath of
the fall of the eastern bloc you saw
what were called
truth and reconciliation hearings now
for those of you guys who don't know
what this is this is particularly
important when it comes to the
post-apartheid landscape
in africa as well as really the the
post-world war
ii landscape in germany with regards to
like the the events that led up to the
nuremberg trials and even after the fall
of the ussr
but truth and reconciliation hearings
were basically a place for individuals
who would experience depression under
essentially a ruling government to get
out there and to basically speak their
truth and that this was oftentimes used
as evidence right people would get out
there and they you would have like these
huge expansive long testimonies where
people would talk about
all the tragedies and all the tortures
they endured they would be documented
and though they would be used when it
came to whatever trials followed for
koslov it was believed that he had
basically suffered enough for the crimes
that he had committed the reality of
this
is that he had connections in all the
right places and so it was a way for him
to basically just kind of
get out and and be allowed to do his
thing because nobody really wanted to
stand against him and so the reality is
that while superman's talking to him
he's kind of asking him about his
company and different things along those
lines and so on and so forth and then
ultimately goes in for like the hard
question right and he asked him
you know do you feel any level of
remorse for all the people who were
tortured and died
under your rule in this concentration
camp and and it's it's beautiful the way
that it's done here
because on one side superman doesn't
really know how this guy is going to
respond but he doesn't really know how
he's going to answer that question
on one side he hopes that he's going to
be exceedingly remorseful and basically
cry and spill the beans about everything
that he'd done
and just show this genuine human moment
on the other hand
superman the the superman part of clark
kent wants him to be unremorseful
unrepentant and just say like hey man
you can't make an omelet without
breaking a few eggs and i'm not sad
about the things that i did because
nikki just uses his heat vision and just
just destroyed this guy right there on
the spot and it's cool to kind of see
superman's anger almost get the better
of him but ultimately
this guy he was neither reformed nor was
he remorseless he just
dodged the question right he basically
just said well i mean we all did bad
things in the past but that's the past
now we're focusing on the future and
that's essentially it
and just sort of goes on from there and
that's that's where things are are
that's where it's so intriguing here
right because the interview with him
ends and ultimately superman's like
there's not really anything that i could
do i mean he could right and that's one
of the things that
that is really established here that
really kind of says i mean superman
could
he could take this guy he could fly into
the sky and throw him into the sun he
could just incinerate this guy with his
heat vision he could do like any number
of things to ruin this guy but the
reality of the world
that superman lives in is not every
problem can be solved
by just snatching a criminal up and just
doing away with him and there are some
individuals out there who will seemingly
just kind of get away with the things
that they've done in the past
that he can take the information that he
has and the statements that kosloth made
and essentially saying that like he's
using cheap human labor in order to
you know build and manufacture products
but the truth about this is that koslov
is not doing anything
that nobody else does and that's what
that's the crazy thing about superman is
he kind of looks at this and says like
sure
koslov is using like cheap labor and and
he is essentially taking advantage of
people he could pay them more but he
chooses not to because
you know he pays them the least he can
possibly get away with but that's the
world as it exists right now right
that's just the nature of of capitalism
right the greatest financial reward for
the least amount of work
it's the way capitalism functions that's
what you and i strive for right we all
strive
for the greatest reward for the least
amount of work so again it's just kind
of the nature of the world that we live
in and it really kind of lives up to the
charter in the philosophy of superman
which is
leading the world into a better place
and so he if he's going to arbitrarily
destroy
koslov for doing what essentially every
capitalist
businessman and on a more micro level
everything that every average normal
person does
then he would basically end up
destroying the world he'd kill pretty
much everybody across the world
because everybody engages in that
practice in some form or fashion over
the course of their life and so
ultimately he's just kind of like does
anybody out there care
if anybody did care the world wouldn't
be this screwed up right people would do
something about it and so i care and so
i'm going to do something right like i
always care no matter what the
consequences are
i will always care this is a
ridiculously great
story right it's just an amazing
superman story and dc needs more stories
like this so with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comics explained
make sure you guys hit the sub button
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you